الى لندن حيث عقد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشيسو سوناك اليوم اجتماع ازمه مع قيادات
قطاع الصحه لحل مشكله الضغوط المتزايده
على القطاع نستعرض الوضع مع مراسلنا اسد
الله الصاوي من امام مقر الحكومه في لندن
اذا ما نتيجه هذا الاجتماع ان يهدئ هذه
الاضرابات اسد الله
في مقر الحكومه خلفيه الان منذ العاشره
صباحا بالتوقيت المحلي الحاديه ظهرا
بالتوقيت بتوقيت الدوحه هذا الاجتماع يعني
يعول عليه رئيس الحكومه والوزراء كثيرا من
اجل محاوله حل المشاكل المتساعده في قطاع
الصحه والتي سببت انتقادات كثيره للحكومه
في الاونه الاخيره يحضر هذا الاجتماع عدد
من الوزراء
بخاصه وزير الصحه ووزير الخزانه وايضا عدد
من كبار قيادات هيئه الصحه العامه هنا في
بريطانيا من اجل وضع اليد على المشاكل
الرئيسيه ومحاوله ايجاد حلول لها بدون
تكلفه كبيره حسب ما قالت الحكومه قبل ذلك
هيئه الصحه الوطنيه
لديها ما يكفي من ام ولا تحتاج المزيد
ولكن يبدو ان الحكومه تحاول الان تغيير
موقفها دون اي خساره سياسيه دون ان تبدو
وقد تراجعت عن الموقف المتشدد اا السابق
الضغوط الاساسيه على هيئه الصحه الوطنيه
والخدمه الصحيه هنا في بريطانيا فقمتها
كثيرا معدلات الاصابه اخيرا في الاسابيع
الاخيره
والانفلونزا معدلات الاصابه هذا العام
تفوق الاصابات في الاعوام الماضيه بشكل
كبير هناك كذلك اثر الاضرابات المتكرره
يومان من الاضراب له هيئه عفوا لي التوام
التمريض في عموم همم بريطانيا باستثناء
اسكتلندا اكثر من 100,000 من الممرضين
وعشرات الالاف من المواعيد التي تم
الغائها كان لدينا ايضا اضراب لهيئه همم
عفوا يتواقم الاسعاف في عموم بريطانيا
ايضا لمده يوم والاسبوع القادم كاضراب
مقرر تتوقم الاسعاف والاسبوع الذي يليه
لدينا يومان من الاضراب مقرران لطواقم
للتمريض كل هذا يفاقم كثيرا من ازمه هيئه
الصحه العامه والخدمه الصحيه هنا في
بريطانيا بعض التقارير اشارت الى ان اقسام
الطوارئ يطرى همم المرضى فيها للانتظار
اكثر من 16 ساعه حتى يتم اا عفوا النظر في
حالتهم ويتم تقديم الخدمه الصحيه لهم هناك
شكاوى حتى من قطاع الاسعاف من ان سيارات
الاسعاف تتكدس امام اقسام همم الطوارئ ولا
تستطيع القيام بمهامها لا يرقاد المزيد من
المرضى وذلك بسبب التاخير من قبل الاقسام
الطوارئ وحتى من قبل الاقسام الطبيعيه في
المستشفيات شكرا لك اسد الله الصاوي
مراسلنا من لندن